ashton harinag from sky news um idris
elba what strikes me the most is on this
panel all six of you are people of color
how
important is that i guess in this
conversation that people who are
directly impacted by climate change in
the way that you're talking about
are hearing from people that they relate
to and my second question if that's okay
to vanessa um you have been a huge part
of this climate conversation and that is
a real credit to you
um how how important is it that you can
change things from the inside and being
part of events like this
we stand here as human beings first okay
as part of this planet but absolutely
yes it is important for
us as proud africans to be a part of
this debate to to to have vanessa to be
a part of this debate in a day and age
where a picture can have both vanessa
and and greta in a picture but vanessa
gets cut out except
they're not just cutting out vanessa
they're cutting out as she said a whole
continent and that continent is very
central to this debate it's very central
to
the solutions you know if you consider i
was born in the 70s
and before the sort of
revolution that we now
say is responsible for damaging the
ozone layer before the aerosol can all
right i was born in that era well if you
consider that africa
is the only land mass in the world where
you can create
a
a
huge
if not
leadership city sustainably well
uh with with led by young people
we are in a position to implement uh uh
influence that now people of color are
on the front lines of the climate crisis
and it's important for us to tell our
own stories and it's important for
the world to listen to our own stories
because
we have been in places of you know
people telling our stories for us but
now it's time for you to listen to our
stories